la fille du fermier puise un
époux que je sois célèbre wayne tous les
meilleures leçons ni à personne d'autre
qui comme toi
c'est pourquoi pourquoi parce que t'es
fait pour être une star
et
temps durs sont bientôt derrière nous ah
oui oui on arrive
on y est on a notre propre décor
maintenant
chercher un endroit où rester des
messieurs
il est vraiment affreux lieu
mais à ma femme qui vit juste à côté
alors j'apprécierais un peu de
discrétion ne va pas
il sait pas ce qu'on fait ici pas vrai
j'aime mieux avoir à demander pardon que
la permission
venir à laterrière mais avec joie
je vais être dans le film tu peux pas
l'histoire peut pas changer comme ça en
plein milieu
si on sait prendre part pas une race
gros ennuis tout allait
bien
je produis quand la nuit tombe
[Applaudissements]
ma femme était dans mon lit
tu dois pas tomber l'équipe suit les
yeux vont leur sortir du crâne quand ils
vont voir ça
c'est quoi c'est
est-ce que tout va bien
[Musique]
ed garçon a trouvé ça à l'intérieur
qu'est ce que c'est à ton avis
je dirais que c'est une sorte de film
d'horreur complètement tordus